so I had this very interesting
experience five years ago you know me
and my husband we were out grocery
shopping as we do every other day but
this time we found this fancy you know
I'm talking Fairtrade I'm talking
organic anton kenyan single origin
coffee that we splurged and got and that
was when the problem started already you
know my husband he teamed this coffee
blend superior to our regular and much
cheaper coffee which made me imagine a
life based solely on fancy coffee and I
saw a household budget explode and worse
I also feel that this investment would
be in vain that we wouldn't be able to
notice this difference after all
unfortunately especially for my husband
he had momentarily forgotten that he's
married to a neuroscientist with
speciality and food science alright
so without further ado I mean I just put
him to the test I set up an experiment
where I first I blindfolded my husband
then I I brewed the two types of coffee
and I told him that I would serve them
to him one at a time now with clear
certainty my husband he described the
first cup of coffee as more raw and
bitter you know a coffee that would be
ideal
for the mornings with the sole purpose
of terrorizing the body awake by it's
alarming taste alright the second cup of
coffee on the other hand was both fruity
and delightful you know coffee that one
can enjoy in the evening and relax
little did my husband know however that
I hadn't actually given him the two
types of coffee I had given him the
exact same cup of coffee twice
and obviously it wasn't this one cup of
coffee that had suddenly gone from
horrible to fantastic now this taste
difference was a product of my husband's
own mind of his bias in favor of the
fancy coffee that made him experience
taste differences that just weren't
there right so having saved our
household budget and finishing a very
good laugh me especially I then started
wondering just how we could have
received two such different responses
from a single cup of coffee why would my
husband make such a bold statement at
the risk of being publicly mocked for
the rest of his life
the striking answer is that I think you
would have done the same and that's the
biggest challenge in my field of science
assessing what's reality behind these
answers that we receive because how are
we going to make food tastier if we
cannot rely on what people actually say
they like to understand let's first have
a look at how we actually sends food
when I drink a cup of coffee
I detect this cup of coffee by receptors
on my body information which is then
turned into activated neurons in my
brain wavelengths of light are converted
to colors molecules in the liquid are
detected by receptors in my mouth and
categorized as one of five basic tastes
that salty sour bitter sweet and umami
molecules in the air are detected by
receptors in my nose and converted to
odors and digital for touch for
temperature for sound and more all this
information is detected by my receptors
and converted into signals between
neurons in my brain information which is
then woven together and integrated such
that my brain recognizes that yes I just
had a cup of coffee and yes I liked it
and only then
after all this noon heavy lifting do we
consciously experience this cup of
coffee and this is now where we have a
very common misconception people tend to
think that what we experience
consciously must then be an absolute
true reflection of reality but as you
just heard there are many stages of
neural interpretation in between the
physical item and the conscious
experience of it which means that
sometimes this conscious experience ends
up not really reflecting that reality at
all like what happened to my husband
that's because some physical stimuli may
just be so weak that they just can't
break that barrier to enter our
conscious mind while the information
that does make it twisted on its way
there by our hidden biases and people
they have a lot of biases as if you're
sitting there right now thinking it
could probably have done better than my
husband you could probably have assessed
those coffees correctly then you're
actually suffering from a bias a bias
called the bias blind spot our tendency
to see ourselves as less bias than other
people and yeah we can even be biased
about the biases that we're biased about
not trying to make this any easier a
bias that we know in the food industry
is the courtesy bias this is a bias
where we give an opinion which is
considered socially acceptable but it's
certainly not our own opinion right and
I'm challenged by this as a food
researcher because when people say they
like my new sugary juice milkshake do
they now are they saying
they like it because they know I'm
listening and they want to please me or
maybe they just want to see him fit and
healthy in my ears I I wouldn't know but
worse they wouldn't even know themselves
even train food Assessors and that's
people who've been explicitly taught to
disentangle the sense of smell and the
sense of taste may still be bias to
evaluate product sweeter if they contain
vanilla why well it's certainly not
because when they'll actually taste
sweet
it's because even these professionals
are human and have eaten lots of
desserts like us and have they ever
learned to associate sweetness and
vanilla so taste and smell and other
sensory information is inextricably
entangled in our conscious mind so on
one hand we can actually use this we can
use these conscious experiences use this
data exploit it by adding vanilla
instead of sugar to sweeten our products
but on the other hand with these
conscious evaluations I still wouldn't
know whether people actually like that
sugar reduce milk shake so how do we get
around this problem how do we actually
assess what's reality behind these
conscious food evaluations the key is to
remove the barrier of the conscious mind
and instead target the information in
the brain directly and turns out our
brain holds a lot of fascinating secrets
our brain constantly receives sensory
information from our entire body most of
which we don't even become aware of like
the taste information that I constantly
receive from my gastrointestinal tract
and my brain will also act on all this
sensory information it will alter my
behavior without my knowledge and it can
increase the diameter of my pupils if I
experience something I really like and
increase my sweat production ever so
slightly if that emotion was intense and
with brain scans we can now assess this
information in the brain specifically
I've used the brain scanning technique
called electro encephalography or eg in
short which involves wearing a cap
studded with electrodes 128 in my case
each electrode then measures the
electrical activity
the brain with precision down to the
millisecond the problem is however it's
not just a brain that's electrically
active it's also the rest of the body as
well as the environment that contains a
lot of electrical activity all the time
to do my research I therefore need to
minimize all this noise so I ask my
participants to do a number of things
here first off I ask them to rest their
head in a chin rest to avoid too much
mass movement I also asked them to
meanwhile stay at the center of a
computer monitor to avoid too much eye
movements and eye blinks and I can't
even have swallowing so I asked my
participants to stick the tongue out of
their mouth over a glass bowl and then I
constantly taste stimuli onto the tongue
which then drip off into this bowl and
then just to complete this wonderful
picture I also provide my participants
with a bit available and either pink or
blue as they please looks like a normal
eating experience right now obviously
not and worse I can't even control what
my participants are thinking about so I
need to repeat this taste procedure
multiple times maybe the first time
their thing about the free lunch that I
provide for participating or maybe the
second time they're thinking about
Christmas coming up and what to get for
Mom this year you know but common for
each response is the response to the
taste so I repeat this taste procedure
multiple times 60 in fact and then I
average the responses because responses
unrelated to taste will average out and
using this method we and other labs have
investigated how long time it takes from
food lands on our tongue until our brain
has figured out which taste is
experiencing turns out this occurs
within the first already 100
milliseconds that's about half a second
before we even become aware of it and
next up we also investigated the taste
difference between sugar and at
official sweetness that in our setup
tastes extremely similar in fact they
tasted so similar that half my
participants could only barely tell the
taste apart while the other half simply
couldn't but amazingly if we looked
across the entire group of participants
we saw that the brains definitely could
tell the taste apart so with EEG and
other brain scanning devices and other
physiological measures sweat and pupil
size we have new gateways to our brain
gateways that will help us remove the
barrier of the conscious mind to see
through the biases of people and
possibly even capture subconscious taste
differences and that's because we can
now measure people's very first response
to food before they've become conscious
of it and before they started
rationalizing why they like it or not we
can measure people's facial expressions
we can measure their where they're
looking we can measure their sweat
response we can measure their brain
response and with all these measures
we're going to be able to create tastier
foods because we can measure whether
people actually like that sugar reduce
milk shake and we can create healthier
foods without compromising taste because
we can measure the response to different
sweetness and find the sweetener that
gives a response that's more similar to
the response from sugar and furthermore
we can just help create healthier foods
because we can help understand how he
actually sends food in the first place
which we know surprisingly little about
first then we know that there are those
five basic tastes but we strongly
suspect that there are more and in fact
using our EG setup we found evidence
that fat
besides being sensed by the texture and
smell is also tasted meaning that fat
could be this new sixth basic taste and
if we figure out how our brain
recognizes fat and sugar and now I'm
just dreaming here but could we then one
day create a milkshake with zero
calories that taste is like the real
deal or maybe we figure out that we
can't because we subconsciously detect
calories via receptors in our
gastrointestinal tract the future will
show
our conscious experience of food it's
just the tip of the iceberg of our total
sensation of food and by studying this
total sensation conscious and
subconscious like I truly believe that
we can make tastier and healthier foods
for all thank you
[Applause]